The empire is growing again.
Grogu, Play time is over.
Everybody come and look.
They've got you outnumbered 10 to 1.
I like those odds.
Long live the Empire.
Welcome back everyone
This is the way. The Mandalorian Season
3 Episode 8 finale is here.
There's a bunch of questions
they still have to answer
about the hanging plot threads
like Who is Moff?
Gideon's Other Spy Inside the Mandalorian?
Who's the traitor?
I think we have
some good theories on that.
I think we have a pretty good idea
who it is.
What's really going on with Grand Admiral
Thrawn and where Ahsoka is right now?
Also got a lot of questions
about what Luke Skywalker is doing while
this is all going on.
Do you think he'd be interested?
Because it seems like it's getting
pretty crazy right now in the galaxy.
If you're new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
The Ashoka episodes will pick up
in the next part of the timeline,
even though it's
going to jump around in the timeline.
That'll start in August.
I'll be doing weekly videos for it,
just like The Mandalorian,
the other Star Wars Disney Plus series.
What they're doing in the finale
will also help set up
what's happening on the Ahsoka series
with Grand Admiral Thrawn,
in addition to the Mandalorian Season 4
and the Thrawn movie,
which I'm just thinking of as the heir
to the Empire movie, they announced that
Star Wars celebration covering the events
of the original Thrawn trilogy
like them re
canonizing a lot of that stuff.
So there's a lot of stuff
that they're setting up
with this Mandalorian Season three finale.
Grand Admiral Thrones return will herald
in the reemergence of our military,
but that was what
the Grand Admiral Thrawn teaser
the Shadow Council scene was all about.
They wanted to reveal
what the rest of the Remnant empire is.
Dave Filoni is calling it
what they're currently doing,
because we've only been focusing
on this one
part of the galaxy the last few seasons
in the book of Boba Fett,
and it's the sector of the galaxy
that's controlled by Moff Gideon.
But he's just one piece of the puzzle.
Like there are a bunch of other
very powerful imperial admirals,
generals, other warlords out there
that are working with the Remnant Empire.
One of the terms we use is,
you know, the war between the New Republic
and the Remnant Empire.
So we're going to see, you know,
you need a conflict,
but it's all in service
of setting up this big Thrawn movie
that'll be like their version of Avengers
Infinity War of Ender's Endgame level
event in the Mando verse.
This part of the timeline
like Thrawn going for Thanos.
Fine, I'll do it myself.
I make all these Marvel references.
But the funny connection here is Jon
Favreau, because he directed the first two
Iron Man movies.
He was also executive producer on
pretty much all the Avengers movies,
including Avengers Endgame.
He said that when he and Dave Filoni
started plotting out The Mandalorian,
the spinoff shows like a Soldier
Skeleton Crew, the book of Boba Fett,
the amount of the way all the shows work,
all the crossovers on the way,
the MCU, the Marvel movies
and the TV shows work.
Even though Dave Filoni is famous
for connecting a lot of dots
behind the scenes,
like a lot of what they did
in this episode helps set up
what's happening in the sequel trilogy,
and he does the same thing
earlier in the timeline
to where, like the bad batch episodes
connect to the prequels, The Clone Wars.
It also helps set up
some of what's happening in present day
with the whole cloning plot.
So together
they're kind of like stitching together
the whole timeline with a lot of these
Easter eggs and connections.
This is the actual official new timeline
that they're using for all the movies
in the series.
They're demarcating things
with the different eras denoted
by different symbols.
Starting 25,000 years ago
with the Dawn of the Jedi movie
that James Mangold is doing,
I've already done
a much bigger video about that,
so I'll post the link in the description
below.
The Old Republic
Era, The High Republic, The Fall,
The Jedi is basically the events
of the prequels, the reign of the Empire.
That's everything between Revenge of the
Sith and a New Hope, the Age of Rebellion.
That's basically everything from the Andor
series to return of the Jedi,
the original trilogy, basically.
Then The New Republic era is the Mando
verse, as we've been calling it.
Everything that's happening
in this part of the timeline
before the sequel trilogy,
The Rise of the First Order is basically
the sequel trilogy in the distant future
in the furthest forward Now.
Like it though, right into the timeline,
here is the new Jedi Order trilogy
that they're setting up
that's going to begin with the new movie
in 2025
set 15 years after the rise of Skywalker.
All talk more about the actual timeline.
When we're in the middle
of all these upcoming series and movies,
because in the future, like the next five,
six years,
we'll be jumping around the timeline
way more like
some of the series
will take place in the past.
Some of them will take place
in the distant future, so on and so forth.
But a lot of you were asking
who the other spy was that they referenced
in the title of episode seven because
it was plural spies, as in at least two.
As you probably guessed.
Moff Gideon has probably had a spy
working inside the Mandalorians
this whole time
since the events of the Great Purge,
and it was super sets of the armor
to just take off playing
right before the Mandalorians
ran into Moff Gideon Super
Commandos in his new dark trooper armor
at the Great Forge.
Like Moff, Gideon
had a trap waiting for them,
so he knew that they were coming.
Whoever the traitor was informed
Moff Gideon about all their plans,
her helmet has the same type of Darth
Maul horns on it that Moff Gideon's
mall DeLorean inspired helmet does
the model Laurean's were the mandalorians
from death watch this supported Darth Maul
during the Clone Wars
after he won the darksaber from the former
leader of Deathwatch who was Pax
Vizsla Paz vizsla as either father
or somehow they were related.
So a lot of people have wondered since
the very first season, like literally
from the start, if the armor used to be
a model DeLorean as part of Deathwatch,
she spent a lot of the episode
talking about what happened to death.
Watch. Do you Deathwatch
Death Watch exists no longer.
It shattered into many warring factions
the way Emily swallowed.
The actress who plays
the armor talked about the character.
She said the armor isn't maneuvering
everyone for her own personal gain.
She doesn't want the Darksaber herself
or to lead on Mandalorian herself.
The actors claim
that she had been trying to push Mando
Bo-Katan to follow what she believes
is the true way for their people.
The traditional way of the ancient
Mandalore like they keep saying,
this is the way.
That's the way the past
this went out to point out for him.
R.I.P..
But there's also the idea that Moff
Gideon,
we need to have a Mandalorian master
blacksmith capable of working beskar
with enough skill to make that new dark
trooper armor that he was wearing.
The armor is one of the few people we've
seen with that kind of skill at the Forge.
Now, she's not the only Mandalorian
or the Galaxy that's capable of that.
There are a lot of mandalorians out there
scattered around.
When she was explaining
what happened to the death
Watch Mandalorians, though, she explained
their group was no more in the current
name of the group was going
by was the children of the Watch.
But she implied that some of those former
members of Deathwatch
were still out there.
Just explain the timeline.
Death Watch was originally exiled
to the Moon Concordia,
as Mando said,
after the Mandalorian Civil Wars,
before the events of the Clone Wars,
that's where Bo-Katan father was killed.
That's how her sister, Duchess, the teen,
became the leader of the Mandalorians
during the Clone Wars.
Then after Darth Maul took the darksaber,
some of them, like Gar Saxon,
who had been Deathwatch,
supported Darth Maul after his defeat
when Darth Maul lost the Darksaber.
Those maul delorean's like gar sacks
turn into the super commandos
that served the Empire,
the ones you now see serving Moff Gideon
after Darth Maul defeat
those death watch Mandalorians
that had not supported Darth Maul
originally reformed their group
as the children of the Watch,
which became the armors group,
basically staying on Concordia in exile
until the events of the Great Purge,
which happened right before New Hope
in when they saw that going down
on the Mandalore planet,
they took off in time
before the Empire found them.
But right now, based on
what they told us in the episodes,
there are only two options.
One, it was the armor
the whole time. Spying for Moff Gideon.
Maybe she had always stayed
loyal to the original Death
Watch even after they disbanded
or the traitor winds up
being one of the other mandalorians
like ax wolves.
But you didn't notice
the timing of the way
they showed the armor leaving the planet
in when they ran into Moff.
Gideon, Super commandos.
I get you seem super sus.
We'll get confirmation
on who it was during the finale.
They're also gearing up
for a big space battle in the finale
between the Mandalorian Fleet and Moff
Gideon Troops.
We saw his new squadron of tire centers
and tie bombers that he had requisitioned,
getting ready to take off
and go after them like he deployed them
just as the episode was ending.
Grogu, who is also probably going
to use his new IG 11 mic body,
his crying body, which they're calling IG
12 to rescue Mando,
who they took to the debriefing room
at the end of episode seven.
I think that was meant to be a callback
to Mando, saving Grogu
you in a similar way from Moff Gideon's
Prison cell during season two on his ship.
Grogu
You just busting in wrecking the hell
out of a bunch of super commandos
using his new mech body, which is super
strong like droid strength
but also using the force.
So expect some crazy grogu
to force powers in the finale.
Grogu going for hulkbuster.
They also teased another standoff
with Bo-Katan in Moff Gideon
so they'll probably have an actual rematch
fight like revenge that Bo-Katan gets
for being betrayed by him
during the Great Purge.
Only this time
she has the darksaber in Moff.
Gideon has the big power upgrade
with his dark trooper Beskar armor.
So imagine her darksaber fight scene
with a scavenger in episode two.
Like a much bigger version of that,
and they'll probably end
the episode with a much bigger grand
admiral Thrawn teaser.
And I love the theory.
The grand Admiral Thrawn will be the one
to ultimately kill Moff Gideon
because they wanted to set this whole idea
that Moff Gideon wants to usurp the power
of the Remnant Empire for himself.
He doesn't really care about what
grand Admiral
Thrawn is doing,
what the others are doing.
He doesn't want the Emperor to come back
either.
You don't need to worry
about cloning the Emperor.
We don't need Palpatine to come back.
But Dave Filoni, Jon
Favreau have said that
Thrawn is meant to be their Thanos level.
That's why it's being thought
of as a Thrawn movie
that they're building up
to on all these different series.
And what better way to set him up
as a major threat than to show Moff Gideon
rally with his new super commandos
killing paths Vizsla or Abby in almost
beating the Mandalorians only to have
Thrawn show up and destroy him easily.
I'm not expecting Moff Gideon to die
any time soon, but it's always possible.
I think they want to tease out the Moff
Gideon versus Thrawn plot where Moff
Gideon just continues to try and usurp
and undermine Thrawn at every turn.
The Remnant Empire in Grand
Admiral Thrawn just shows him who's boss
like a
Thanos Post-Credits scene kind of moment.
Fine, I'll do it myself. But it's grand.
Admiral Thrawn also really hoping
for a cameo scene from actual Ahsoka
because she hasn't
shown up this season yet.
And we have the Ahsoka episodes
coming really soon
and they want to push into that.
As for Luke Skywalker, for those asking
what he's doing right now,
he's still trying to establish his Jedi
Academy.
He's looking for force sensitive trainees
and trying to keep them safe.
So he probably has an idea
of what's going on.
Like R2 would be keeping in communication
with the rest of the galaxy
just in general, but for the most part,
Luke Skywalker's Academy on Access
is meant to be as cut off, as protected
from the rest of the galaxy as possible.
Like he wants to keep it relatively
anonymous so the thousands and thousands
of people and potentially other villains
don't come looking for him.
I do believe, though,
that he will become a much bigger part
of the actual Thrawn movie.
Like that's when they're going to do
all the really crazy stuff.
Like everyone has theories
about how they're going
to bring characters back
and like other big characters
that might show up
during the Thrawn movie,
if they were going to do more Luke
Skywalker, they would do it during that.
If you have any of the big questions
about the hanging plot
threads or what's happening
with Mandalorian Season
four or the Big Thrawn movie or Ahsoka,
just write it below in the comments.
There were a couple other big trailers
that there was an extended Ahsoka trailer
with even more footage.
I'll do a video for that
the next couple of days.
There are also a bunch of announcements
about really huge TV series
in trailers, so I'll try to do videos
for everything the next couple of days.
Everyone click here for all my brand new
Star Wars trailers like the Ahsoka Trailer,
Star Wars Acolyte and everyone, click here
for all my Mandalorian episodes.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe.
This is the way.